[Música]
bienvenidos a medio ambiente en france
24 cada año el fondo mundial para la
naturaleza wwf lanza el desafío de
ciudades una competencia en la que un
jurado internacional de expertos en
sostenibilidad urbana evalúa los
compromisos y las acciones que las urbes
del mundo están poniendo en marcha para
alcanzar los objetivos del acuerdo de
parís de 2015 entre los criterios que
tienen en cuenta está en el compromiso
político los reportes de emisiones o sus
acciones de mitigación contra el cambio
climático en el desafío 2019 2020
ciudad de mexico se llevó el premio
tanto en la categoría nacional como
internacional para comprender un poco
mejor la relevancia de esta competencia
me acompaña vía skype desde la capital
chilena
la líder global de wwf ciudades jennifer
lenhart jennifer bienvenida a france 24
hola buenos días porque son tan
importantes las ciudades para revertir o
frenar la crisis climática pues utiliza
las ciudades son el hogar del 55% de la
población global y del 80% en
latinoamérica son también responsables
del 70 por ciento de las emisiones de
carbono del 75 por ciento del consumo de
recursos y del 80 por ciento del pib
debido a su población a sus emisiones y
en su consumo son instrumentales para
alcanzar el acuerdo de parís y su
objetivo de limitar el calentamiento
global al grado y medio centígrados las
ciudades no sólo contribuyen al cambio
climático sino que son cada vez más
vulnerables al clima extremo calor
extremo contaminación del aire y riesgo
las infraestructuras el cambio climático
empeora esos retos existentes en muchos
aspectos y lo estamos viendo ahora con
la pandemia de kobe 19 el secretario
general de la onu antonio guterres dijo
recientemente que las zonas urbanas son
el epicentro del cob y 19 con el 90 por
ciento de los casos reportados ahora es
el momento de volver a pensar y
reajustar el cómo vivimos
vamos y reconstruimos nuestras ciudades
así que la pregunta es en qué tipo de
ciudades queremos vivir ciudades que
priorizan a las personas oa los
vehículos ciudades con mejor acceso a
espacios verdes no solo para facilitar
el distanciamiento social pero también
para aumentar la resiliencia sin embargo
las buenas noticias son que las ciudades
también son lugares de prueba lugares
para probar nuevas ideas y nuevas
tecnologías y a pesar de los retos que
enfrentan están moviéndose hacia la
dirección correcta pero necesitamos
información y datos para saber en qué
están y los progresos que están haciendo
y por eso en w w
lanzamos el desafío global de ciudades
para apoyarlas y para progresar hacia el
cumplimiento del acuerdo de parís pues
muchísimas gracias ya níjar lenhart por
su tiempo en france 24 como mencionamos
antes este año ciudad de mexico se llevó
el premio nacional y global y por eso
también nos acompaña desde la capital
mexicana jorge ricard director de wwf
méxico bienvenido
gracias muy buenos días buenas tardes
buenas tardes
qué hizo qué ciudad de méxico ganará
este año que la distinguió de las demás
ciudades
el nivel de ambición de los datos
sometidos de los planes de la ciudad de
mexico con respecto a la viabilidad para
cumplir los acuerdos de parís el acuerdo
de parís que implica mantener por debajo
de 1.5 grados el aumento de la
temperatura global las ciudades como ya
se dijo son elementos importantísimos en
términos de la contribución que pueden
hacer los países a cumplir esta meta y
la ciudad de mexico como una de las
ciudades más grandes del mundo tiene una
responsabilidad particular de cumplir
con su parte los planes que ha venido
sometiendo en la ciudad de mexico con
respecto a cuánto quiere lograr y
también el nivel de viabilidad y que
tanto eso contribuye a la
responsabilidad que tenemos respecto al
acuerdo de parís eso eso es lo que se ha
evaluado por otro lado también criterios
como el contraste entre esa viabilidad
ese nivel de ambición y también los
retos que enfrenta la ciudad
específicamente los temas de cambio
climático también se evalúa la
estructura gubernamental la capacidad de
compromiso
y oficial de cumplir con estos planes
también la trayectoria durante los años
méxico lleva cerca de 20 años la ciudad
de mexico cerca de 20 años reportando
datos específicos sobre temas concretos
que contribuyen a su reducción de gases
de efecto invernadero y finalmente
también la comunicación de estos planes
y la involucra el involucramiento de la
ciudadanía es la primera ciudad
latinoamericana que recibe el premio de
capital global del desafío de ciudades
usted hablaba antes de los retos de
ciudad de méxico pero cuáles son los
mayores retos ambientales a los que se
enfrentan las urbes de toda la región
latinoamericana
pues dado que la tendencia en
latinoamérica es a mayor concentración
urbana de hecho latinoamérica es la
región más urbanizada del mundo la
presión que esto ejerce sobre los
recursos naturales también pues va en
aumento y es asociada y eso es parte del
gran reto en nuestras ciudades es no
están libres de grandes concentraciones
de personas de retos como la pobreza con
altos niveles de desigualdad y todo esto
se traduce en presión sobre los recursos
naturales específicamente pérdida de
bosques cambio de uso del suelo mayor
exigencia de agua mayor presión sobre
los recursos hídricos que conjuntamente
llevan a una degradación que es muy muy
peligrosa las ciudades vamos hacia el
80% de las personas en ciudades en los
próximos años ejercen por lo tanto una
presión muy fuerte una huella ambiental
muy fuerte que incluye también la
generación de alimentos agricultura
etcétera
en nuestra región desgraciadamente ha
perdido cerca del 90% de poblaciones
especies lo cuales son un indicador
tremendamente importante y las ciudades
poder contribuir mucho a frenar este
interior pues muchísimas gracias jorge
muchísimas gracias jeannifer nuestros
dos invitados del programa de hoy ya
ustedes recuerden que hay mucho más
medio ambiente en france 24 punto com
[Música]